how's it going bros my name is beautiful
so I'm supposed to play Lego Jurassic
world with my step but you have to go to
Italy so it looks like I'll just play
this by myself my sin oh you made a I'm
so glad we can play another one any time
my Amina okay so this game is all about
collecting little Lego coins
alright okay your name Jason subscribed
jump I'm sorry I'm sorry my sin I love
you so much my sin after the video is
done I promise
please don't stop don't stop
did you show them I'm not looking thank
you I can't jump on this today
especially good I don't know what
changed
these are pigtails are the pigtails in
my life for the first time and I'm also
wearing these trousers which look like a
dress that is so well in this game so
far I'm so proud are you my husband your
house I'm your husband did you not know
that we have cutter mattock
leave a comment with congratulations
I know you have a lot of extra hair too
but I guess that's that's Italians are
kind of hairy nothing other than so
proud of you thank you you really become
such a gamer and such a beautiful voice
I love when you sing okay don't don't
chain to give Ana it is I bought it for
you I know thank you so much it was a
very expensive you look great in it
thank you to be honest you can't even
see the dress it just looks like you and
they would do that
like that
[Music]
otherwise anyway now you have to
president numbers you are freaking
kidding me what did you do yeah I'm
bringing it up
this is dead that was so easy okay I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I
the old planted the trap card every
girlfriend has the tumblr post I'm so
tired of playing with you might go one
sec come back what do you want
as always we ended with the brofist how
does that work no no you do the fist
like this like it is yes and then you
broke this together I remember from our
relationship I'm so sorry money
I'm sorry mother yeah I don't know the
name of your shoes
[Music]